yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing speaker 74 you still get a six
more so the time thing the bull end is
not that popular really in those on
those somewhat more normal levels ok I'm
going to play for an ending here against
bigger this is not all that all that
much but let's see what he how he how is
he has against us and yeah f5 is a
typical way to play against this this
this line he prepares this very quickly
[Music]
you know f5 problem to indo right up at
85 there ok we'll see what what he does
this some playing for c5 also makes a
lot of sense of course
the very end game heavy line the
exchange variation 96 but quite sure
maybe Bishop before as an idea okay so
we have quite sure what blacks point is
here 95 maybe 35 to see 400 lane okay
well this is a new soul
just taking the f 4 square ok so it
seems like he really wants to go to c4
yep that may it makes sense it
absolutely does make sense ok I'm just
going to put it on c1 the bishop
but ever really clear plan how'd you get
something something going here not okay
it's not easy for blog either maybe be
sure to see one night and five some
point I would like to trade minor pieces
here wants to get closer to a good
ending but nice is very a very active
him so looks like f for the special
g-form probably I can prepare that I
mean I didn't totally know what I
therefore helps okay here should g5
becomes more interesting but so it
doesn't do much me2 was hanging some
that's still annoying f25 film I don't
know if that is a good idea right here
but I want to do something I don't just
want to sit around I'm really not just
not sure that this does this helps me
[Music]
yeah 95 now is interesting and there's
be three and the night now it doesn't
really have good squares yeah I can push
the night to a 500 let's do it yeah 95
now this is always stuff like f5 which
looks annoying that has to like to do
this also because Knight f6 can be can
be good
interesting
f5 looks looks look so good as somehow I
was worried about 95 okay so what to do
now
really want to get out of that diagonal
that that makes me extremely nervous now
I have more more ideas like a night if
so might have six now is good it's a
simple and good move yeah yeah that's
good that starts to look like a good
ending you sighs or I cannot do this for
Bishop at six and then he five threatens
to win material okay yeah at the ending
is going to be nice for me right back
yeah that's comfortable ending the night
ending is really good probably is going
to go back with then I've got Bishop f6
no it's not going to go back yeah 94 why
doesn't really feel dangerous okay so
okay how to play here 95 is the easy way
to do it is actually take the pawn and
95 that's it's already pretty strong
[Music]
check time morning it's not fun for
black sticking out you can go in to use
that fork
yeah c6 is a pretty awful weakness 96
King III cannot cover it anymore check
[Music]
check check check check check check um
[Music]
check I should pay some attention here
okay
just let's see it I didn't pay attention
I read through wins but check black for
fits on time okay yeah I didn't play the
opening well he really had a nice
position like roughly here but I think
some decisions didn't didn't help like
so here I mean 95s actually move
actually thought about when i was i was
at 5i was right with him i have 90 of
six as i wanted to play it you should do
that as just my father most principled
choice okay so who what a mess and then
delicious a equal greater yeah i think
after you didn't do that it got here
Alex from here it got to god awful the
immunity five was just wrapping a piece
yeah that was better I was just looking
for this I was just happy with this
excellent ending I didn't think about
that much okay now that this is a very
good ending I don't think that computer
valuation is correct i think white is
quite substantially better here okay
okay here i'm winning a winning upon
which fire prospector but you know why
it is basically a poor knock those two
points here on the queenside don't count
and i can try for ever and ever to play
this ending
and most likely one will succeed in the
long run ok guys thanks for watching